where the [ __ ] do I find em I am so whoa
I found a base there's a road a lot of
dirt road I have without the blocks guys
I need help is on being a pig shirt but
I need because I ever had oh my god get
hat get two hat get your hat get your
hat yes I have a high
I never was wearing the Hat you guys are
gonna see little later it's gonna be
awesome
all right there's a burning car it's a
color green is it
do you see an airport an airplane yes oh
hey okay what about me we will come find
you now it's gonna be very [ __ ] savvy
this is great we're going 43 kkm
kilometres yeah I'll have 11% fuel
though off-road all right here sorry I
swear to God a haircut wait I hear a car
do you see around you I think you're on
the other side of that hill in the grass
around a road you're on right there you
are coming what where there's that he's
in the ground the Sam is in the grant
where are you oh hi hi friends are you
it no I'm not it's full ah God oh [ __ ]
oh god is it really full pink so it's an
I don't know in the back climb on the
truck okay okay I'm through with the car
now Jesus oh well looks like you're
[ __ ] weight you look great though I
know I have a hat you know I hear can't
you just run them over
can't you just yeah yeah yeah thank you
touch alright dutching oh did away yes
it did but there's still a few of them
come back in savings how do you do
yeah do you love them Duke boys you do
yeah expert ah that's more I'm smacking
their asses die Adam off oh do it did I
just hear we strap through him
did I just killing me okay did are you'd
um dad oh [ __ ] again oh no these are all
same bees your name carries your name
funeral me would you run me over we went
to only better
he's got a bad don't take my badge me hi
guys I got us this pants yeah oh yes oh
yeah good yo here I can't tell
Wow oh yeah nice head okay my hat dude I
just found it wow I'm gonna [ __ ]
murder you guys yeah it's dark now and
I'm alone with no family or hands locks
Daisy all right we're gonna find pewds I
watched this long a road earlier
I've ever known doneita bakers but it's
only me and I waka right
to be selling me my
your naina
never
and your senses
me down there
I'm in the water
[Music]
okay good good we've done it we
butchered it enough
let it die let it die okay
bond last time I swim across the web
there's a helicopter pad here yeah yeah
I've been there
guys please I don't know where that is
I need in Chinese all I know what the
air - gasps I found a gas cane oh [ __ ]
that's like finally good I find total
gas canes that's actually really really
and I found a care that's I don't know
what the [ __ ] that with 5% better s I'm
out of here
you get some gay Church church Church
it's a Jewish Church all right I'm gonna
church until I find yes
okay keep shushing Josh josh Josh okay
I'll see you lights go forward where the
tree which tree no get off my car I'm
gonna murder you no she don't say no get
off my care your safety she's son of a
[ __ ]
all right win it okay when we come back
oh god if we come back to safety
I'm gonna matter you just know that are
you two things still ha how do I get
here I don't remember like crossing the
ocean whoa God
did you see it is random randomly were
there you go back in the bay sometime
where stuff I guess all right I guess we
might have a little mall yeah yeah
all right here we are oopsie roadblocks
God really you can't go through it I I
don't think so
all right let's find some [ __ ] when it's
light speak be careful Ken okay
I don't want anything to hurt you where
are you Ken
uh I would I'm right come on come out
today
si you the neikei yeah why are you naked
Oh a dad that's really close let's go in
here baby easy careful
what are you doing
there's a Sam be over there I killed him
you're welcome
all right camera because I want to help
you mm right Hey
who's that in your hand Wow not H stop
it yeah why didn't you die you're gonna
don't you dare take that card don't you
dare take that card listen to me you
piece of [ __ ] I will destroy you you not
going anywhere [ __ ]
all right I don't have any more ammo so
you're OK for now right here we go you
ready no that's a terrible idea
we're going oh my god you guys oh no
it's what for me I can't I can't kill
you're swimming naked it is like the
most smart guy
get a good look at it there's the car
get your [ __ ] smile - oh my god
there's a bridge health do you have I
shot you 14 days I'm not telling you
don't die now how a big thanks I had a
pickup for them
I'm by the boat remit cry cry I'm by the
barn
now where are you I'm in the bag the
back of the barn yeah you see Rio I see
a lot of dead Zambezi yeah that's me
I see a cry over there fighting for his
life yeah they will done quite a lot of
zombies be careful there can't care cry
oh Jesus
Jesus ah oh I feel your zombie he killed
you again
[Laughter]
isn't it funny it's great for [ __ ]
half my screens in black-and-white cuz
I'm so low it like you're a zombie I
said I saw you yeah we're right on me
I'm sorry for you I know I know and I'm
sorry
mistakes happen this can I need to
scatter them happy accept it I'm so out
of line now I know where you are now
[ __ ] I get do it I don't have
any weapon I don't know how but I will
find you yeah and I will I literally
don't think I can get out no I get it
wait good I know you're in there no I'm
stuck where are where where is he this
is really a thing huh wake up
are you [ __ ] with me so I hope
journeys come across molestin haha hey
brah zombie witty so much loot in Baja
oh this shirt is gonna look so much
better on me oh my god it's gonna look
so good and I'm on the other side of the
map I'll tuck for my side thank this it
looks like that one hat that I had in
the beginning what are you gonna do bet
it just a hat traded heads good luck
hand it over
sorry I didn't mean Angie alright are
you scared now that I can defend myself
I didn't know you could yeah I'm losing
blood
what the [ __ ] yeah me too why do
business how we die alright we're gonna
die we're gonna die like a man
Thank You kid my hat in my head often
put it on your dolly